mein thema heute abend ist gerhard
schröder die spd spitze hat altkanzler
schröder zu recht nämlich jetzt ein
ultimatum
sein posten verzichtet gestellt spd
vorsitzenden lars klingender und saskia
esken haben den früheren parteichef und
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder in einem
brief ultimativ endlich in meinen augen
dazu aufgefordert seinen posten bei
russischen staatsunternehmen
niederzulegen man erwarte eine zeitnahe
antwort das hat lars klingbeil heute auf
einer gemeinsamen digitalen
pressekonferenz mit essen nach einer
sitzung des parteivorstands gesagt
sollte schröder der aufforderung die
bereits am vergangenen samstag erfolgt
seien nicht nachkommen werde man über
das weitere vorgehen beraten schröder
sei zitat komplett isoliert in der
sozialdemokratie sagte klingbeil ich
kann nur sagen endlich er hat auch
gesagt im parteivorstand gebe es
niemanden mehr der show das verhalten
auch nur ansatzweise gutheißt oder
rechtfertigt nicht nur die spd
distanziert sich von gerd schröder die
stadt hannover will altkanzler gerhard
schröder die ehrenbürgerwürde entziehen
einen entsprechenden entschluss der
verwaltungsausschuss am donnerstagabend
einstimmig gefasst und damit das
offizielle verfahren eingeleitet
voraussichtlich am 31 märz wird dann im
rat darüber entschieden aber ich frage
mich wie lange wird schröder diesen
druck der noch bereit ich nenne das
verlogen ist mal klar zu sagen niemand
hindert die bundesregierung die mehrheit
im bundestag daran ein gesetz zu
erlassen das es deutschen generell
untersagt führungspositionen in
russischen unternehmen
auszuüben das sollte längst passiert
sein da muss man nicht an schröder
appellieren dass er irgendwann von
alleine geht man muss es ihm einfach
verbieten und dann ist der fall erledigt
aber das tut natürlich deshalb keiner
weil deutschland und die bundesliga
machen ja weiterhin geschäfte mit der
gazprom sie importieren ja russisches
gas also wie sollen sie dann als
regierung gleichzeitig dem man verbieten
bei dergahspor meiner funktion auszuüben
ich komme da noch drauf später die
deutsche politik ist aus meiner sicht
verlogen immer noch nicht ehrlich und
das merken wir auch an falsch rüber
lassen sie also wir alle sollten einmal
beim fall schröder finde ich direkt
bleiben weil es alt kanzler verbieten
hier ist vor allem man muss eben hier
geht hier gibt es ja vor allem auch noch
ein ganz sondern hintergrund er ist ja
nicht ein ganz normaler bürger der keine
leistungen vom staat bekommt und
irgendwie guckt wo kann er geld
verdienen dann wäre das schon schlimm
genug aber er bekommt ja mehrere
hunderttausend euro über mitarbeiter
über jedes jahr eine entschuldung eine
entlohnung bis ans lebensende die der
deutschland steuert damit erneut kann
sein auto habe mir das nicht mal vom
deutschen steuerzahler und der
hintergrund dieser entlohnung und auch
dieses mitarbeiterstabes und der
infrastruktur die er vom deutschen
steuerzahler bekommt ist ja dass er den
deutschen staat auch als altkanzler
repräsentiert so wie das viele
altkanzler und auch altbundespräsidenten
immer gemacht haben und das hat ja mit
repräsentanz nichts zu tun dass
beschädigt deutschland politisch im
ansehen in der ganzen welt und deswegen
ist es überfällig dass diese gelder vom
deutschen steuerzahler sofort
eingestellt werden bei den nächsten
haushaltsberatungen muss eines klar
gestellt werden gerhard schröder darf
kein büro mehr finanziert bekommen keine
mitarbeiter mehr finanziert bekommen und
auch seine entlohnung die er bis ans
lebensende als altkanzler
eigentlich bekommt die müssten
eingestellt da steht ein bisschen kopf
verlassen also weiter zu dass er bei der
gas kommen und bei der rosneft in den
aufsichtsräten sitzt und neben dem er
seine kleine gelber weg wir müssen ihm
das verbieten bin sogar überzeugen kann
wenn ein wenn ein deutscher staatsbürger
wenn ein deutscher staatsbürger sagt er
will nach russland ziehen und ihre
mitgas verarbeiten es kann man das nicht
mehr machen da kann ja hinziehen aber
das kann man ja nicht verbieten der
erreichte dann hat euch auch kein büro
mehr genau aber mir geht's also mir geht
es ja darum dass man sagt der deutsche
steuerzahler darf kein euro mehr an
gerhard schröder bezahlen und ausgeben
für gerhard schröders infrastruktur
liegt und wenn wenn sie herrn schröder
stehen dann im steht immer noch kopf man
muss verbieten dass der mann für
russland arbeiten das ist der zentrale
das können sie nämlich in der wir leben
ja in der chemie energie und jeder
ratssitzung kann man das beschließen
kann aber nicht und ich halte das für
möglich dass er irgendwo dankbar ist
weil ihm die entscheidung abgenommen
wird er fühlt sich doch aber da geht das
geht rechtlich nicht also sehen könnten
ich würde ich gehen man könne ja auch
nicht verbieten für gazprom zu arbeiten
wenn sie sich jetzt nach der sendung
entscheidender moskau zu ziehen und
vergast zu arbeiten ist dass ihr recht
was aber man politisch entscheiden kann
ist dass sie nicht auch noch gelder von
der deutschen steuer und eine menge
sanktionen gegen russland warum soll das
als sanktionen nicht möglich sei
natürlich ist das möglich es ist sehr
viel möglich auch dass es ist eine form
von schröders unterstützung für das
kriegführen russland das kann man
verbieten ich vermute mal das ja auch
deshalb so loyal an putin hängt weil er
seinen fehler einfach nicht eingestehen
will und weil ihm putin adoptivkinder
besorgt hat spielt in seinem leben eine
große rolle nehmen wir ihm die
entscheidung ab verbieten ausschluss
vergesst schröder eine darf nicht mehr
für russland auch eine eine
eine frage dazu die mich interessiert
weil mich das ganze auch sehr
beschäftigt hat obwohl ich hier bin habe
ich mit gerd schröder sozusagen
politisch aufgewachsen bin ich von da an
für politik interessiert habe als er
kanzler wurde kurz zuvor
und wenn man sich überlegt was das ganze
jetzt für ihn bedeutet er wurde bei
borussia dortmund
wurde ihm glaube ich die mitgliedschaft
entzogen er kriegt den druck bei der spd
da muss man ja eine sache auch noch
wissen lars klingbeil und gerd schröder
waren einmal engst befreundet bis vor
wenigen wochen bis die dieser krieg
ausgebrochen ist bzw eskaliert ist lars
klingbeil hat man bei gerhard schröder
im büro gearbeitet gerhard schröder hat
in seinem bundestagswahlkampf wahlkampf
gemacht und so weiter und so fort auch
dass ein zerwürfnis er ist bei ringier
ausgeflogen er steht in der
öffentlichkeit als buhmann da diejenigen
die ihn vorher noch verteidigt haben
haben sich abgewendet spätestens seitdem
wladimir putin hier zivilisten in der
ukraine bombardiert warum macht er das
wirklich ich frage mich mittlerweile hat
vladimir putin und damit will ich gern
schröder nicht in schutz nehmen aber ich
frage mich das hat wladimir putin
irgendetwas gegen ihn in der hand denn
ansonsten macht das doch für einen
politisch denkende mensch auch wenn er
daran glauben sollte dass er irgendwie
wladimir putin mag warum auch immer ja
ich meine das ist ein kriegsverbrecher
aber es würde doch ist logisch spricht
nichts mehr dafür dass gerhard schröder
weiter daran festhält vielleicht
prologis erkennt den wahrscheinlich am
längsten
ich habe ja schon gesagt ich vermute
dass ich hinter seiner anhaltenden
loyalität zu putin auch die kinderfrage
steckt er sich wahnsinnig persönlich
nahe und er ist ein typ der einfach
fehler nicht eingestehen kann er hat nie
einen fehler eingestanden er bringt es
nicht fertig das muss man ihm abnehmen
man muss ihn da rausholen verbieten und
dann in hannover wo er lebt vergessen
dann soll das sich überlegen wann er
zurückkommt in der öffentlichkeit mit
welcher erklärung aber jedenfalls dass
die spd nun appelle an ihn richtet finde
ich völlig daneben die spd soll dafür
sorgen dass das nicht mehr tun darf aber
und darauf kommt persönlich enttäuscht
ich und soll mit einem tisch gegenüber
zum beispiel da warst du ja gar nicht so
stark gegen schröder wie es jetzt voll
beispielsweise schon vor wochen war ist
auch eine persönliche enttäuschung
niemanden lange ich bin auch sehr
persönlich enttäuscht von russland das
werde ich gleich noch erläutern